it's okay to waste money on bad  employees and bad coaches in order to  get to good coaches and it's the same  thing with Outsourcing and hiring people  I was very quick to Outsource people  like before I even I paid people more  money than I made a lot of people are  afraid to spend money on people what if  you waste your money now in business you  are going to waste money do not spend  any money that you need to make back  don't because you won't and at the first  couple months you are just gonna lose  money but it's worth it because  let's say I hire a bad employee or a bad  coach I know what to look for in the  next coach so I know what not to get